exciting
[Music]
hour
of the day
we're very pleased to have alex
basakovic from uh facebook ai research
and you have the first stop take it over
hi um hi everybody yes my name is alex
um i'm gonna
sort of uh hopefully give a
a lighter uh less math heavy talk to
kind of uh wind down the day um so
this actually is
um rather than talk about kind of one
paper in depth i figured i would
go and talk uh about something that i
and a bunch of uh collaborators have
been working on for actually quite a few
years um at this point
um and it's sort of a common thread that
runs through a bunch of papers
and it's about how
ideas from machine learning can be used
in game theory and and the idea of using
machine learning to build game
abstractions
so this sort of comes from um a kind of
perspective of like game theory as
engineering um
there's kind of multiple uh ways to take
that but really i i typically think of
the engineering part of game theory is
either doing something like agent design
right so we have some strategic
situation we need to build maybe an ai
agent um that needs to go and enter it
and we want it to do well whatever well
happens to mean in this case
or you know mechanism design where we
know we're going to have some strategic
agents and we're actually designing the
game um such that their interactions are
going to give us some kind of outcome
that we like
and these two things have in common that
um in practice
you know we're gonna often face very
complicated environments um and we're
going to run into
a lot of computational results that tell
us that even in simple places um things
that we might want to be things that we
might want to compute are very hard to
compute and so
uh if we want to scale it we often can't
just like brute force it
so
the idea um but i'm going to be talking
about today is you know again we didn't
invent this this has been around um for
a long time and i really want to think
about the work on poker ai um as a place
where this idea of game abstraction uh
you know kind of really took off
and the idea of an abstraction is you
know imagine that we have um some game
so we want to build an agent that's
going to be good at let's say two player
no limit texas hold up
um so we kind of this is a two player
zero sum game with imperfect information
so we know that what we'd really love to
do is compute a nash equilibrium
and then just play that strategy when we
go and play someone and hold them
um and
the problem with that is that even
though we know how to compute these
equilibria um when you have you know
this many nodes in your game tree
you're going to wait until like the
death of the universe before you're
going to get your equilibrium strategy
so the idea of of of abstractions at
least in in the poker um literature at
least in the earlier poker literature is
sort of
changing
or has changed um
is you know we have
kind of
hand-tuned heuristics where we say okay
well we're going to take some of these
nodes in our tree and we're going to put
them together because they're really
kind of the same note or we're just
going to ignore certain parts of the
tree because we're never going to get
there
and we use that to basically take our
big game make it into a simpler game um
solve for the nash in the simpler game
and then we're going to play the the
nash strategy in our original this is
kind of the the poker way of doing
abstractions
and
you know i'm going to talk about a
couple of things that we've been working
on which all sort of have the following
pattern we're going to take a
complicated game
um we're going to
we know from
game theory how to solve a kind of
simpler version of that game uh and then
we're going to use some kind of machine
learning technique as the little bridge
between well how do you map this into
this and then ideally this is sort of
invertible in some way um and we're
going to lift the solution up to uh the
big game
so
the first um kind of example that that i
want to talk about and this is what got
us uh into this research uh is thinking
about playing social dilemmas
um so you know this is the prisoner
dilemma this is like the most studied uh
game theoretic concept i think of all
time um you know like biologists do this
psychologists do it like everybody talks
about this and the reason that this is
so popular is not because we really care
about these like two action you know two
by two games but it's because we think
that
repeated personal islamism in particular
repeated prisoners dramas are kind of
like natural abstractions of lots of
situations that we face in reality
um and so
there's this whole
line of research um which you know i'm
gonna sort of point back to this kind of
like axelrod uh tournament where
people are basically saying okay if
we're going to be playing i'm gonna you
know i'm going to build a strategy for
the repeated prisoner's dilemma
so that when i match with a new partner
i do quote well right and well here
again sort of depends on what uh the
paper means but i think in general it's
kind of like i want to have high payoffs
kind of like no matter who i get
this is kind of the zero shot um
coordination or cooperation um
environment
so
again giant literature uh on all of this
um that
sort of encompasses a general family of
strategy that do these three things
so first of all they say well a good
strategy sort of cooperates when your
partner cooperates it defects when your
partner defects right so it punishes um
and then it allows that if you did
defect on me but then you start being
nice to me later we go back to
cooperation so the actual way you do
this right if you think about like the
simplest of these is tit-for-tat which
is like copy what the guy did before but
there's like a giant family of all of
these that all kind of look like this so
we've sort of converged on this is the
way to play repeated uh two-player
prisoner storms
okay
so
let's think about you know let's scale
up from the the you know two by two game
to this very simple grid world um let's
say i am blue you are red we can walk in
all the cardinal directions um and
randomly uh coins will appear on the
spirit world they're either my color or
your color
if you pick up um
your uh coin then you know let's say uh
you get a point and if you pick up the
other guy's coin um you know you get a
point but they lose some points
right so
obviously like when i describe it you're
like well this is just like a bigger
prisoner's dilemma because there's a
strategy called cooperation which is
pick up your own color uh and there's a
strategy called defection which is just
go around and try to eat ever
but when you think about like an rl
agent an oral agent doesn't have these
kind of you know high-level concepts of
cooperation and defection
their policy in rl is just a mapping
from states which is you know what is
what does the board currently look like
and maybe what is you know a kind of
history of play
um two actions which are walk up walk
left walk right walk down
so
the basic idea here is going to be and
this is kind of our first uh two papers
on the topic is going to say okay well
let's use
reinforcement learning or deep
reinforcement learning right so for this
you can do kind of standard tabular
things but you can as soon as you start
getting bigger you've got to start
using some function approximation etc to
map our policy space
so that now our policy space is going to
look like cooperative effect
so
kind of the basic algorithm um you know
in these and then a couple follow-up
papers is we're thinking about a world
where um we have a we're separated uh
yes that's the clarifying question yeah
it states i mean the key thing for
reinforcement learning is what
the
algorithm reinforces so what are your
states here that that's a that's a great
question um
so
the choice of state you know typically
we sort of think of it as like well when
i give you the mdp the state space is
presented but actually in you know
practical reinforcement learning the
choice of the algorithm that you're
using to do the learning
sort of also defines the state space
right so if you have something that has
memory then the state is you know board
state plus some memory clicker
right whereas if but if you just have
something that inputs the state and out
mean sorry the state meaning the board
position
um then that's your state so and in your
case what's the state
sorry
in in the results you're going to show
us what did you take to the state space
so so here in in all of these papers we
um
look at the state as just
um
what is visually available right so here
the state is going to be
where are the players on the board and
where are the coins if any on the board
thanks
so
we're going to take um but that's a
great that's a great question um and one
which i kind of we talked a lot about in
the papers i wanted to sweep under the
rug for the talk but of course you
caught it
so um anyway so we're thinking about a
world where we have two phases we have a
training phase where we have access to
the game
and we can use that to construct
whatever we're going to do
and later in the test phase we can use
the policy that we constructed in the
training phase with a new partner
so in the training phase we're going to
do two things
um we're going to construct a policy
just using here you can do this with a
tabular ra algorithm but you can also do
it with a you know your favorite
multi-agent reinforcement learning
algorithm um
but you give it control of both agents
and then you construct the policy which
optimizes the sum of the utilities
now you pull that policy apart for an a
and a b agent and that's your c policy
now you do the same thing um imagine
that you know at test time you're gonna
play as player one we're going to
construct uh a policy for player one
which is going to try to minimize player
two's utility and we're gonna allow
player two to kind of maximize against
that if we want and that's going to be
our d policy or our punishment policy or
or a minimax policy uh you know if you
want to think about it in like a folk
theorem kind of sense
and then the new partner phase
right what we're basically going to do
is we're going to do exactly what
something like the folk theorem would
tell us to do so we're going to use the
cooperative policy
we're going to somehow detect whether
our partner is also using a cooperative
policy or not and then we're going to
respond appropriately
so
again now we're sort of getting into
like well what's the trick about how do
you actually choose um whether how do
you actually detect whether your partner
is using a a c policy or not
um you could see if they're matching the
actions that you want them to match but
actually in practice it's very fragile
and doesn't really work and so what we
come down to in the two papers is that
essentially there's two ways that seem
robust
one is you use the q function from your
learned cooperative policy to sort of
look forward right so you say okay well
this my partner took action a
um and
that has affected my q value by
you know whatever some amount
now had they taken the power the action
that i thought that they were going to
take under the cooperative policy what
would have been my future value right so
now i'm saying
how are you affecting my future value by
your actions today and when you know we
sort of sum that up over time and when
that starts getting low we start saying
okay this guy is probably cheating
and sort of choosing again the threshold
is going to depend on how much noise we
think the other person has etc etc
you can do that or you can look
backwards at the realized payoffs which
is sort of a
uh
simpler but
has other disadvantages
um where what you basically say is okay
well we've been playing for 10 rounds
um and i know that when we're both
cooperating i sort of expect a payoff of
20.
let's check my current payoff well if my
current payoff is sort of you know 20
plus or minus some amount i say okay the
person's probably cooperating um and if
i look at my payoff and i say oh you
know look uh it's it's lower than i
expected
this guy's probably cheating so you know
then we start defecting so again very
similar to what you would expect from uh
once you've written it down in this form
it's very easy to apply kind of folk
theorem style intuitions to how you
actually go ahead and swap between these
policies
so
this is sort of our um
our prisoner's dilemma version of this
but um you know we've actually thought
about applying very similar kind of
abstractions and
and i don't want to go into too much
detail kind of here at the sake of time
but um similar ideas we've applied to uh
to coordination games um and uh sorry
it's a stag hunt games and then i think
kind of importantly to these
coordination games where um
you know it doesn't really matter what
we do as long as we do the same thing
right so in this paper we kind of study
driving right it's really important that
we both drive on the left or both on the
right side of the road
or here we think about um a cooperative
card game uh hanabi so anyway just kind
of
if you're interested uh this this these
ideas go far beyond um the prisoner's
dilemma but the thing that i want to
sort of um
also mentioned in this talk is you know
that was sort of agent design now let's
talk about abstractions for market
design
um so
let's think about a very simple
environment um fisher markets we have a
market there are n buyers there are m
goods each good has a limited supply
each buyer has some budget b
an equilibrium in this market is an
allocation of goods to individuals and a
price per goods such that the allocation
that i give to each person maximizes
their utility
given the prices in the budget and the
total allocation is supply fees right so
basically you have a demand curve you
have a supply curve you cross them
so
we might care about computing
equilibrium allocations in these markets
for various reasons
one really nice uh sorry one reason why
is this is actually a mechanism with
very nice properties so um there's this
idea of competitive equilibrium from
equal incomes
um which is a mechanism when you have a
bunch of items and you want to assign
them fairly to individuals
so the way that cei works um is you say
okay
why don't you all report your valuations
for each item to me
maybe a combination of items you know
kind of depending on the language that
we're allowing
we give you a budget of fake money
we solve for um the equal budget
equilibrium of this market and i hand
you back the allocations that i've just
computed
so this is really nice because it's
going to have it's going to inherit a
lot of really nice properties from the
market equilibrium in particular there's
going to be no envy
when the market is large it's going to
be incentive compatible um
and in the linear
uh additive case it's going to maximize
national social welfare so it's kind of
like just a good mechanism um it's
actually used in practice and in
university course allocations uh in a
bunch of places
the problem with it
is it's not very scalable in the general
setting because with general utilities
we have a lot of hardness results about
a computation of equilibrium
and even if you think about the very
simplest case which is additive
valuations and divisible goods meaning
lotteries
yes you could say you could you can
solve this with a convex program
but
you know
n to the 100 is polynomial time and
yeah that's that's not a scalable
solution that's just polynomial time um
and this
kind of happens to be one of those
problems
um
[Music]
yeah this is ovarian is is sort of the
original
um
um
so i mean buddhism is you know where all
of this stuff starts getting actually
used all of the course allocations like
course potential
it's not that fast if you have a million
buyers
again like
so we can talk about flying but um you
know
you it's
having actually tried to do this at
scale like
yes you can solve it with either the
context program or there's a bunch of
like uh primal dual approaches
like if you make your market of like
size a million by million like
it doesn't like yes if you have servers
it's gonna work but
it's not gonna scale
even bigger things
so they allow
they have
additive but they also allow some
amounts of complementarities um
and
they also don't do randomization right
so so they do kind of
um
unit they're sorry like history demands
so you have to solve a
myth in order to do every demand
so that's what makes it actually quite
slow
um
the divisibility thing actually is not
that big of a deal like in practice all
these things
i mean they also don't want
um
multi-unit demand right so if there's
like 10 seats in a class they don't need
to get
five
so
so it's it's a little bit of a
that that problem has its own spaces
but they must have a lot of students
right so are they taking whether it
leads to solvers
so in one of the papers in one of the
earlier papers they talk about um
basically they run it
at that point they say okay we have
you know a cluster and we run it
overnight on a cluster
um to get this and you know i think
they're doing per
don't quote me but i think they're doing
per year
and then somehow combining it but i'm
not i'm not sure like but basically yeah
it sort of works at that level but if
you do like 100x that there's no way
that stuff is going to scale
they're not quite arbitrary
because they so remember it depends on
the language that you allow people to
actually express and i think they only
allow you to express
um
they allow you to express valuations and
then they have um
you know conflicts right so you say you
can't get this course in this course
because they're at the same time and
then i think also they do prerequisites
somehow
so it's it's not like general utilities
and again for general utilities like
you might not be able to find anyone
right
so it's it's a class of utilities where
you can get
um
integral solutions but
it's not yeah
so
again let's just think about the sort of
uh divisible and additive case for a
second um and you know so in this paper
we sort of say okay how do we how do we
do some abstraction um to solve large
versions of this
um
and so
what we are basically doing is the
following idea so
you know in the additive visible case
you can just write down evaluation
matrix where the rows or buyers columns
are items
um
one thing that we know how to do in
machine learning is approximate uh
matrices by lower rank versions of those
matrices
um you know even if you have like
missing values or things like that
and then the idea is that once you have
an approximate uh a um you know left and
right factorization of your valuation
matrix you can think of these as
embedding vectors for your buyers and
your items
now take your favorite clustering
algorithm you know in the paper we do k
means but it doesn't really matter which
one you do um and now
cluster your uh your embedding vectors
and what you're essentially doing is
you're taking your buyers and your items
and you're kind of like clumping them
together so like these two buyers become
one buyer and these two buyers become
one buyer and these two goods become one
good and so on
um
and because of the way that you have
that you factorize the valuation matrix
you can actually just take the centroids
of your clusters and now sort of impute
valuations for each representative buyer
for each representative good so now
you've got the subtracted matrix which
can actually be like
quite a bit smaller than your original
matrix
you solve your equilibrium of uh your uh
abstracted matrix and then you just go
ahead and you lift your abstracted
equilibrium by just saying okay well you
know this representative buyer
represents these five buyers and he's
got these items and so you can split
them you know kind of evenly or you can
do some kind of recursive splitting uh
within each buyer
so
it's gonna be a lossy abstraction
um you know we do have a uh
i think a fairly obvious kind of theory
result uh in the paper the quality of
your um you know in terms of like
mechanism design quality measures the
quality of your solution um compared to
the actual optimum is going to be sort
of
linearly proportional to your
factorization loss and your clustering
loss um
the thing that i think is is a bit
neater is you know in the in the paper
we actually collect a bunch of data sets
um where people express willingness to
pay
for various
items
and what you see if you just do like a
buy clustering on the matrix evaluations
is that these things do have kind of low
rank and clustered structure so it means
that
you know this
the the the more of this structure these
things have the lower this loss is going
to be and the better your approximate
solution is going to be compared to what
would be your real
um
anyway so that's kind of you know we
then go ahead and have a bunch of
different other
you know ways of because this is
basically a building block right like
any time you're going to do a linear
additive utility in an equilibrium you
can always do it in the abstraction
and so
we sort of talk about this if you want
to do this in robust utility
maximization you can kind of do it
online
it has a lot of connection to
incorporating these sort of algorithmic
fairness
ideas
because a lot of the algorithmic
fairness ideas can be expressed in terms
of the buyer vectors that you end up
getting
um and then
sort of
you know it's connected to things like
shapley value computation um in
cooperative game theory
anyway so
um tldr um
we got to do a lot of computation when
we do engineering and game theory many
cases we know how to solve simple
versions of games but we can't really
scale it um
we can take machine learning abstract
big things
solve our simple solutions lift the
solution back up
um
cooperation coordination market
equilibrium computation
again not saying that we've
nearly exhausted this idea i think
there's a lot more to go um here so
yeah thank you
thank you very much uh alex for the very
interesting intriguing work
uh
we have a lot of questions i guess
already and please let me know if there
are anything oh yeah nothing in chat
right now okay
hi um i'm really curious to know about
the fish market application that's like
a really highly decentralizable
computation
um i mean whether if you want to do it
you know with distributed comics
optimization or just there's like
algorithms uh
to do that
like it seems like that should be
something that you could handle millions
of like buyers and goods if you do the
right optimization like
there's it's the simplest type of market
so going through the
abstraction you're losing
guarantees
and i'm not sure actually if the
computation becomes that much easier
than if you actually decentralize
everything
um
i mean so
i'm not a convex optimization
expert my co-author on those papers um
does happen to be so sort of a better
question for him but
you know
he's seen like the fact that he came and
went and wrote a bunch of these i think
the same actually co-authors have a
logarithmic time like computation
guarantees for the linear fish market
yeah so it's not really well
there are sort of like
theory optimization guarantees and then
like you actually go ahead and actually
run the optimization and it
like is the issue that you don't
actually have linear utilities in the
applications you care about no way we
think about linear
linear utilities um
i mean
you know again like it it also doesn't
have to be either or right like the
point of the abstraction is that what
it's doing is it's reducing the size of
your of your optimization problem
by
kind of i understand that point but i
think what's more interesting is if you
actually were able to abstract out a
market that was more that was harder
that we can't actually compute things
for like something like an everyday
market onto efficient market and then
you were able to compute it but
otherwise you're taking a problem that's
already easy to compute and reducing it
to something that's even easier to
compute while losing guarantees
yeah i mean
i think
uh
so i'm gonna disagree that it's easy to
computer practice um
but but that's fine um
you know that being said um
you know the the linearity
is not
okay so what are other classes that you
can do this kind of abstraction
so i think that a very similar
abstraction technique can be applied to
um if you allow kind of pairwise
complementarity
right where
um
because you can write pairwise
complementarity preferences as kind of
uh
is that leonty you mean no no no no not
leontya so so this is kind of like a
long do you want to talk about this
offline okay because
yeah now i have a question with the
answer okay
no no no go and go
yeah let's i think that uh it's an
interesting question uh and
you know there are traders right i mean
there's the
hi yeah really interesting thanks so
with regards to the first part of the
talk i really like the idea of defining
a cooperative policy as you know binding
two agents together in a cooperative
setting first and then taking that
policy afterwards but if i understand it
correctly you define cooperative policy
as just maximizing the sum of the
utilities in this case and i guess this
goes for like simple prisoner dilemmas
yeah but it would also see like maybe
this is orthogonal to so you're
optimizing for efficiency maybe this is
orthogonal to like equality in some
cases for example in some prisons lms if
you have the the defective payoff be
very very high in comparison with the
cooperative one so how do you deal with
that
so
uh
the that algorithm right you don't have
to really the cooperative policy can be
anything right so you can say that the
cooperative policy is the thing that
you know
um maximizes nash welfare right the
product of the utilities and then and
you can train it in exactly the same way
and then you can apply the the sort of
folk theorem logic in exactly the same
way which is i watch what you do
if you're if you're maximizing the nash
welfare then i also do it and otherwise
i minimize
your welfare right now now you need sort
of guarantees about that the min max is
actually lower right like i can sort of
punish you enough to get you to do the
things that i want but
but it's a it's a general
thing about enforcing kind of whatever
payoff you like
okay so you can go for whatever metric
you want or even comment questions yeah
right okay the important thing is that
the thing you're trying to enforce is
also a thing that the other person
agrees is a good thing to enforce
because otherwise
yeah that makes sense yeah all right
thanks
okay
um also a question on the first part um
these sort of high level
strategies you have to hand engineers or
prisoners to them but defect cooperate
for coordination go on the same or not
do you see any way of trying to automate
that part as well that you extract out
the relevant high-level strategies
um
okay so this is a place where i actually
have a lot of disagreement with like
a lot of other people in in morrow um i
think there's a bias in
machine learning or ai or whatever you
want to call it to sort of like do
everything from the data you know like
oh we don't want inductive biases like
we want like
you know we want it to come from nothing
but
like why
you know like we wrote like
you know we we've written like hundreds
and thousands of papers about the
prisoner's dilemma and we like
understand how social dilemmas work and
we like
you know we've sort of converged on an
answer and it seems like
throwing you know like
why throw it away i mean i'm thinking
what i could then apply it to a game but
you don't know yet what the high level
strategies are
yeah so so there's i mean there's
versions of this um you know jacob
forrester has a series of papers
where
what they do is
essentially you do reinforcement
learning but you
within your let's say policy gradient
you include the other guy's policy rate
so now you sort of like take actions to
get that person to maximize your reward
um
so when you do that in like these
prisoners dilemma like generalized
person whatever you want to call them
games um you end up with things that
look like tit-for-tat because we
no that's the answer um
you know
it's unclear
yeah like
i guess we just sort of like need more
context right like but yeah yes if you
don't know the answer you could probably
do other stuff but if you know the
answer you should definitely hard code
the answer because okay you know the
answer
i guess sorry but as a follow-up to this
like
aren't you suggesting that sort of like
you in principle you can implement some
kind of like you can use the effectively
the folk theorem to
you know kind of like
uh you know force uh
as well for a maximizing thing like in
any game
i mean this is this is basically what
we're doing right so like because what
does the folk theorem want it says what
is the thing that you want and then you
know what is the thing that you're going
to do if you don't do what i want
and so that's kind of what we're
computing the the one
trick
with with the rl part is
how do you detect
like what does it mean for you to not do
the thing that i want right that's the
thing that becomes because in in the
you're just a normal form stage game
you're like yeah you didn't do b so like
you know we're done um but
i guess your suggestion is to look at
the payoff that i was expecting to get
if i get worse payoff then i'm gonna
well right but it depends which way
right you can either look backwards at
your real life payoffs or you can look
forwards at your expected past and
there's kind of trade-offs to each one
right so i guess in relation to that
question you can do that in any game
even if you don't know it a priority
right like definitely like two-player
games it's very clear what you wanna
what this might be right
yeah well but again like you also want
you want the other person to actually go
along or the other player to actually go
along with what you're doing right so
like
i get 90 of the value
like folk theorem enforceable like are
you actually gonna do it i don't know
uh yeah so it's kind of a follow-up
question to what uh we we've been
discussing so basically what you have in
mind if i understood correctly is a
setting in which you have imperfect
information
and so
um
i was wondering you know in practice you
know since basically you're motivated by
practical issues you also typically have
been complete information which
basically means that
as you were saying what cooperation
means
depends here i am what's my prior over
the payoffs which means that sometimes i
might you know
step into a
relationship in which we're both
cooperating we just don't realize it
right because you know my
and so
which is kind of um
[Music]
natural right in complex games which is
a natural application so it would be
nice to see you know how this works
actually in practice
yeah in settings with incomplete
information so so the
the algorithm that looks backwards at
your realized payoffs right works in
incomplete information
um
you know the but then i guess the
question where you put the threshold
right right there you go but but you can
but you can only set the threshold kind
of empirically right so you roll out
like you have all these strategies so
you roll them out a thousand times and
you say okay let's say the the fifth
percentile the tenth you know
right like you can you can follow a
quantile and and the quantile is like
how much do i let you get away with
possibly cheating at the expense of
by accident you know
starting a nuclear war yeah but also
what has in mind is that if you train
them you know using their own subjective
knowledge on what the total payoff is
and now we disagree on you know what the
total payoff is we might end up with
different strategies which means you
know
that we again
you know my payoff sucks it's not does
not suck because you're not cooperating
you're cooperating in a different way
and i just not realize it yes
no i i mean and this this is always the
problem right that like
you know
you
you also need these cooperative
strategies to be like compatible in some
way
right so
i mean
it's just a harder problem and and i
think there's no real
like you know if you think about some of
the coordination um stuff that we've
done and other people have done right
that is a lot of
this question of okay well there's
multiple ways
that we can achieve the high payoffs
together how do we
pick one
um and i sort of view that as a separate
problem
from the like
well is this person
cheating or not um but like i agree you
have to solve both to do a thing that
works
uh very interesting discussion uh
we're running out of time so let's thank
alex again and take everything